okay uh dion are you ready to read some
stories with us yeah
okay well first up taylor swift's red is
still making headlines fans are up in
arms all over again about all too well
the song that she allegedly sings about
ex-boyfriend allegedly jake gyllenhaal
allegedly
the aftermath has been so intense that
one company is stepping in to offer
relief to
jake
travel and leisure reports that app in
the air a travel app is offering 300 in
flight credits to five guys named jake
they're holding a contest right now for
any and all jakes who want to get out of
town
now
dionne in the song taylor sings about a
scarf that jake
um
never returned yeah but you offered to
return it
um is this correct yeah it is i offered
to pay the postage to give that girl
i love these tweets
[Applause]
i love it
can you can i be a fly on dion's wall
and just ask like when you saw that your
first instinct was like i'll get it back
for you yeah it was yeah you know i felt
that first of all what was he gonna do
with the scar
i mean it does not belong to him it
belongs to her give the girl a scar back
yeah thank you
thank you
well apparently
ups
agreed with you and responded to you and
said this one is on us dion
how fun is that it's wonderful i love to
i love you i i use ups and downs
by the way i got all hot and bothered
when ups got involved too i was like no
it's a real party yeah it is okay wait i
gotta get your thoughts on adele have
you listened to the new album i haven't
heard it no you have oh you gotta hear
it i've been listening to it on repeat
anyone else yes
well now we all may get a chance to hear
adele's new songs live and this is
breaking news rolling stone reports
adele has just announced a las vegas
residency
yes
it's called weekends with adele and it
kicks off this january and runs every
single weekend in eight until april at
caesar's palace and to get tickets you
have to register with ticketmaster now
so everyone go pre-sales start uh next
week you've had a vegas residency right
would you have any advice for adele
she's starting a residency there and at
caesar's where you had your residency
she's gonna have fun she is i've been
doing vegas since 1969.
well actually and you have a brand new
single yes i do that just dropped that's
right with chance the rapper wow
how does this collaboration come i love
this you know i tweeted about him
an iconic tweet
that's the first tweet that got reaction
uh when i asked him i said we all know
that you're a rapper why do you put it
in your name
he responded you know and it was like oh
he really was okay
and we started conversing and finally i
got his phone number and i called him i
said i just recorded a song and i want
you to record it with me how about that
he said yeah
that's okay
well here we are here we are
you've had such an extraordinary life
and i was just wondering you know it's
the holidays and sometimes i really ask
advice from people i love takeaways
is there any sort of life advice or
mentality or something to try on
what is your advice for us as we go out
of 2021 and into 2020. you know i uh
i've gotten to the point
at my age these days
that um
parties don't mean anything anymore to
me you know people say well are you
going to defeat your birthday this year
well again for my birthday it's going to
be a charitable event
kind of music
is an academy my son started
and it's a way of letting kids know that
they can take control of their lives
musically
and it's an educational
and
thing and we're going to do that we're
going to be doing a
benefit
at
brookburg's house which is wonderful
she opened her home to us and brooke
burke yeah that's so lovely yeah she
opened the home and we're going to be
raising money
for operation smile oh wonderful
so you know it's it's like
that's what i want people to do start
thinking about
giving of self again you know we've lost
sight of it
oh thank you dion warwick i love you and
i'm so glad that we got to be in person
finally we've been waiting for you to
grace us with your presence and we're so
honored that you're here my pleasure my
darling and thank you for inviting me
and you got a beautiful audience you
really do
thank you
thank you
[Music]